Okay Charles, what have we learned? And I mean
specifically in the context of this game theory two lesson.
>> That's a that's a good question. We learned
about Iterated Prisoners Dilemma. Which turns out to be cool,
and it solves the problem, and we learned about
how we can connect iterated prison's dilemma to reinforcement learning.
>> What do you mean?
>> Through the discount.
>> Yeah, so I think of that as being the
idea of repeated games.
>> Right. Let's see, what else have we learned? So we learned about
iterated prison's dilemma, which allowed us to get past this really scary thing
with repeated games, connected it with
reinforcement learning. The discounting. And then we
learned other things like for example, I
don't remember. What, what did we learn?
>> Well so the, the connection between iterated prisoner's dilemma and
repeated games was the idea that we can actually encourage cooperation.
And in fact, there's a whole bunch of new Nash equilibria that appear
when you work in repeated games. That was the concept of the Folk Theorem.
>> Right. The Folk Theorem. So, the Folk Theorem
is really cool. And this whole notion of repeated
games really seems like a clever way of getting
out of what appear to be limitations in game theory.
>> Right. Yeah. And in particular by using things like threats.
>> Right. But only plausible threats.
>> Right, so that
was the next thing we talked about. The idea
that an equilibrium could be subgame perfect or not,
and if it wasn't then the threats could be
implausible. But in the subgame perfect setting, they're more plausible.
>> Right let's see and then we learned about Min-max Q.
>> Well there was one last thing we did
on the repeated games, which was the Computational Folk theorem.
>> Yes you're right. So basically what we learned
is that Michael Littman does cool stuff in game theory.
>> Or at least he does
stuff that he's willing to talk about in a MOOC.
>> Yes, so that's, that's there's actually a
technical term for that right? MOOC acceptable research?
>> Oh, I didn't know that.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So all these things are by virtue of the
fact that they showed up in this class look acceptable.
>> Exactly.
>> Alright, you're right, but then we switch to stochastic games.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And they generalize MDP's and repeated games.
>> Anything else?
>> Well, that particularly got us to min-max
Q and then eventually to Nash Q. But
despite the fact that Nash Q doesn't work, we ended up in a place of hope.
>> [LAUGH] We end with some hopefulness.
>> Yeah, and you know, I think that
that's actually a lesson for the entire course.
That at the end of the day, sometimes
it doesn't always work, but there is always hope.
>> [LAUGH] We don't give up and that's, that's, that's how research works.
Even when we have impossibility results for things like clustering, or
multi-agent multi-agent learning and decision
making, we still keep struggling forward.
>> And keep learning, and isn't that what's really important. I think so.
>> Its important for us, and its important for machines.
>> Yes, that is beautiful. I feel like we've made
it to a good place, Michael. Perhaps we should stop.
>> [LAUGH] Well it has been, it has been
delightful getting to talk to everyone, and it has been
very fun getting to talk with you, Charles.
And thanks to everybody for making this happen.
>> I agree. And we have one more chance to talk with one another as we
wrap up the class. And I look forward to that. So, I will see you then, Michael.
>> Awesome. Do we get to see each other in person for that?
>> We get to see each other in person for that. That will be fun.
>> Yay!
>> Okay, well, bye, Michael. I'll see you next time.
>> Bye. See yeah.
>> Bye, bye.